[Music]
[Music]
every year the world's most elite
mountain bikers gather in France for a
race unlike any other
it's the longest untundi race in the
world that's right McGavin lanch is the
longest downhill race in the world 18
miles long ten thousand feet high in the
French Alps and a crazy starting line of
three thousand cyclists on a mountain
peak this is Remy Epsilon he won the mag
Avalanche I start 110 bike when I was
young and euro and mountain bike is
really cool because we can explore all
around the world
McCollum's shall / us take place since
French sharks in Hartford us so not so
far Atari and Switzerland it's a vdi in
harps so you have a very good view 360
degrees around you it's really crazy I
don't know why I do that
you write all kind of terrain so it's
classy and after the rocky sections
Forest is very physical with some
happens so when you cross the line and
you are first your you will ARP and you
want to try again
I think the only real way to push a
eco-conscious agenda is to just make the
things that are eco conscious a little
more sexy ready Freddie
my name is Josh Adar I'm a metal
sculptor my artistic platform is
sculptures bikes that all have the same
theme of eco consciousness and
sustainability ah
solar energy there are lots of electric
bikes out there but I don't think you're
gonna get a whole lot of interest
without that bike being a real
head-turner I learned how to weld this
the University of YouTube I didn't
really have anything in mind to build
when I started to weld I just loved the
process this bike not only runs on solar
energy but it was completely created by
solar energy the same system that I used
to power the batteries I used to power
all my hand tools and basically all of
these are made strictly by hand tools
and then basically once you buy it
there's virtually no costs you know you
don't have to gas it up you don't know
whatever it's all learned from the sky
from the Sun
once I had my kids my priorities really
changed and that was just you know I
want a cleaner planet
the penny farthing was the first machine
to be called a bicycle
[Music]
they're old they're funny and for some
still a big deal sometimes I go into
local bike shop just for a bit of a joke
and a specific type spit my bike and
bring them out so I kind of look at it
people find the penny farthing almost
hypnotic I don't know why I can't
explain it but people just love seeing
it I mean it's just a real pleasure to
share it with people
Richard being an already avid bike racer
discovered penny farthing racing on an
internet forum one night so entered
immediately
we're excited then realized that a
hideout for penny farthing and be I
don't know how to ride a pony filing but
he overcame those hurdles I'm the
current UK champion so I've got title
defend but penny farthing racing isn't
as easy as it looks and it sure doesn't
look easy it's a very dangerous machine
to ride you sat up on top on the point
of balance virtually so if anything goes
wrong you tend to be going headfirst
over the front of the bike
the bikes can be up to five feet tall
and that height has its benefits Racing
one of these bikes are pretty high up
you get a fantastic view of the crowd
it's the best way to see the event here
I always tell people height is not the
only benefit the penny farthing has big
difference between riding a penny
farthing a normal bike is you can't slow
down really quickly you got to watch the
road ahead but I find the biggest
difference is the smiles on people's
faces when you ride one of these things
people just look to see it they smile
they wave they pull up take photographs
at so many conversations with people I
would never ever meet without this bike
and that's that's the joy that people
just love seeing it talking about it
Oh
[Music]
Wheelz come out very low read bicycles
is special everything a special frame in
special wheels a special paint
everything is special the bicycles we
make is make with law because it's with
our hands
you know those bikes snoop and countless
other rappers wrote around in you know
the ones that lose that West Coast style
lowrider bikes low to the ground chromed
out gold-plated they're an extension of
lowrider car culture and they all
started here I am the Godfather of the
lowrider bicycles when I was 10 years
old the bunch of the neighbors always
dreamed with a motorcycle and a car but
since I was too small in no money so I
put my mind and bicycles a mainstay in
Compton and West Coast culture these
iconic bikes were actually first created
in Mexico I brought the lowrider to
California in early 80s and soon after
locals took notice of the shiny swaggy
rides hanging in the shop when I start
making bikes and put it in a display
people come and they say can you make me
one of those and then they spread and
now we have customers from all over the
world this is one of Managed creators
right here
I almost packed we put everything on
there
blew my mind when when you put it on
here for me it's a completely different
than the regular pike and the way they
look and the way they drive is art
people's dream and we make the dream
come true
[Music]
you
Oakland really will chew up and spit you
out
like I guess nothing you know cute we
get killed every day you know living I
hope nothing is promised tomorrow you
know so if I'm going tomorrow what
legacy what I leave behind on my name is
tyrone stevenson also known as baby
champ discovery bike king and i'm the
founder and the CEO of the original
schedule i take alright because it's my
lifestyle i don't know it just makes me
express myself even more you work with
you that lives in the community and
teach them how to make their bicycles
for students you know for kids to be a
part of the team you have to have at
least a 2.0 GPA some of them like it
some of them don't but at the end of the
day they have to respect it if they want
to be a part of this team we use
different bike parts to make one big one
and make it look better
back basically fix anything on the bike
now scary ride team teaches you how to
you know customize your bikes put
aluminum foil and duct tape and spray
paint on the bike and you know make nice
sky bark is bigger than his life regular
bite is just a regular bike I ride
scraper bike because I like the way they
look you get to show it off and say you
made it yourself yesterday was our grand
opening of the [ __ ]
the first Youth brand bike shop
ever in Oakland I found it the original
scrubber by team officially 2007 and
with my cousin eggs it's a bittersweet
feeling to open up the show you know
just knowing that my cousin Avery isn't
around you know just to see you know
just to have his presence here because
it was killed it wasn't murder
[Music]
senseless and I'm gonna do it nothing I
feel like this whole movement is
dedicated to him
you know and I do this because one day I
might not be here and somebody else
could step into my place and keep it
going
[Music]